you know humans they don't care about
mean square error solution or maximum
likelihood solution they just want the
sound to sound better for them and it's
about human perception that's one of the
very tricky parts in audio signal
processing you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
after decades of research in processing
audio signals we've reached the point of
so-called performance saturation but
recent advances in machine learning and
signal processing algorithms have paved
the way for a revolution in speech
recognition technology and audio signal
processing dr. Yvonne Tasha a partner
software architect in the audio and
acoustics group at Microsoft Research is
no small part of the revolution having
both published papers and shipped
products at the forefront of the science
of sound on today's podcast
dr. Tasha gives us an overview of the
quest for better sound processing and
speech enhancement tells us about the
latest innovations in 3d audio and
explains why the research behind audio
processing technology is thanks to
variations in human perception equal
parts science art and craft that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Evon Tasha
welcome to the podcast thank you great
to have you here you're a partner
software architect in the audio and
acoustics group at Microsoft Research so
in broad strokes tell us about your work
what gets you up in the morning what big
questions are you asking what big
problems are you trying to solve so in
general in audio and acoustics research
group we do audio signal processing that
includes enhancing of a captured sound
by our microphones better sound
reproduction using mineral audio
so-called spatial audio we do a lot of
work in audio analytics recognition of
audio objects recognition of the audio
background we design a lot of
interesting audio devices our research
range from applied research related to
Microsoft products to a blue sky
research far from what is Microsoft
Business today so what's the ultimate
goal perfect sound perfect sound is a
very tricky thing because it is about
human perception and this is very
difficult to be modeled using
mathematical equations so the classic
statistical signal processing was
established in 1947 with a paper
published by Norbert Wiener defining
what we call today the winner filtering
the approach is simple you have a
process you make a statistical model you
define an optimality criterion make the
first derivative make it zero voila you
have the analytical solution of the
problem the problem is that you either
have a approximate model then find the
solution analytically or you have
precise model which you cannot solve
analytically the other thing is the
optimality criterion in all humans they
don't care about mean square root
or maximum likelihood solution they just
want the sound to sound better for them
and it's about human perception that's
one of the very tricky parts in audio
signal processing so where are we
heading in audio signal processing in
the era of machine learning and neural
networks the machine learning a neural
networks are capable to find the
solution from the data without us making
an approximate model and this is the
beauty of this whole application of
machine learning in signal processing in
the reason why we achieve significantly
better results than using statistical
signal processing even more we train the
neural network using certain cost
function and we can make the cost
function to be even another neural
network train it on human perception for
better audio which allows us to achieve
better perception of a higher quality of
the speech enhancement we do using
neural networks I am NOT saying that we
should go in every single audio
processing block using machine learning
in neural networks we have processing
blocks which have a nice and clean
analytical solution and this runs fast
and efficient and they will remain the
same but in many cases we operate with
approximate models with not very natural
optimality criteria and then this is
where the machine learning shines this
is where we can achieve much better
results and provide a fair quality of
our output signal one interesting area
of research that you're doing is noise
robust speech recognition and this is
where researchers are working to improve
automatic speech recognition systems so
what's the science behind this and how
our algorithms helping to clean up the
signal we are witnessing a revolution in
speech recognition the classic speech
recognizer was based on so-called hidden
Markov models or hmm in these servitors
quite well but the revolution came when
neural networks were implemented in
training to do speech recognition my
colleagues in the speech research group
were the first to design a neural
network based speech recognition
algorithm which instantly showed better
results than the existing production
hmm based speech recognizer the speech
recognition engine has one channel input
while in audio processing we can deal
with multiple channels so-called
microphone arrays and they give us a
sense of speciality we can detect the
direction where the sounds came from we
can enhance that sound we can suppress
sounds coming from other directions and
then provide this cleaner sound to the
speech recognition engine the microphone
reprocessing technology is combining
together with techniques like sound
source localization and tracking and
sound source separation allow us to even
separate to simultaneously speaking
humans in the conference room and feed
to separate instances of the speech
recognizer for meeting transcription in
serious yes we can do that even more the
audio processing engine has more prior
information for example the signal we
sent to the loudspeakers and the goal of
this engine is to remove the sound which
is interfering for our sound and this is
also one of the oldest signal processing
algorithms and every single speaker
phone has it but in all instances it
have been implemented as a mono acoustic
cancellation in Microsoft we were the
first to design stereo and surround
sound echo canceller despite a paper
written by the inventor of the acoustic
echo cancellation himself stating that
stereo acoustic cancellation is not
possible and it's relatively simple to
understand you have two channels between
the left and the right speaker coming to
one microphone so you have one equation
into 'knows and Microsoft releases as
part of Kinect for Xbox a surround sound
echo cancellation engine not that we
solve it - nose from one equation but we
just found workaround which was good
enough for any practical purposes and
allow us to clean the surround sound
coming from the Xbox to provide a
cleaner sound to the speech recognition
engine so did you write a paper and say
yes it is possible thank you very much I
did and it was rejected with the most
crucial feedback from the reviewers I
have ever seen in my career it is the
same to go to the French Academy of
Sciences and to propose a terminal
engine they have decided since 18
century not to discuss papers about that
when I received the rejection notice I
went downstairs in my lap started the
demo listening to doubt what ok it works
so we should be fine
[Music]
one thing that's fascinated me about
your work is the infamous anechoic
chamber or chambers as I came to find
out
at Microsoft and ones right here in
building 99 but there are others and so
phrases like the quietest place on earth
and where sound goes to die are kind of
sensational but these are really
interesting structures and have really
specific purposes which I was interested
to find out about so tell us about these
anechoic or echo free chambers how many
are there here how are they different
from one another and what are they used
for
so the anechoic chamber is just a room
insulated from the sounds outside in our
case it's a concrete cube which does not
touch the building and sits on around
half a meter of rubber to prevent
vibrations from the street to come into
the room and internally the walls the
ceiling and the floor are covered with
the sound absorption panels this is
pretty much it what happens is that the
sound from the source reaches the
microphone or the human ear only using
the direct path there is no reflection
from the walls and there is no other
noise in the chamber
pretty much that any quick chamber
simulates absence of a room and it's
just an instrument for making acoustical
measurements what we do in the chamber
is we measure the directivity patters of
microphones or radiation patterns of
loudspeakers as they are installed in
the devices we design initially the
nuclear chamber here in Microsoft
Building 99 the headquarters of
Microsoft Research was the only one in
Microsoft but with our engagement with
product teams it became overcrowded
and our business partners decided to
build their own any quake chambers and
their today 5 in Microsoft Corporation
they all can perform the standard set of
measurements but all of them are a
little bit different from each other
for example the quietest place in the
earth as recorded in the Guinness Book
of Records is the anechoic chamber in
building 88 and the largest an equal
chamber is in Studio B which allows
making measurements with lower
frequencies than in the rest of the
chambers in our chamber in building 99
it's the only one in Microsoft which can
allow human beings to stay prolong at
amount of time in the chamber because we
have air-conditioning connected to the
chamber it's a different story how much
effort cost us to make the rumbling
noise from the air-conditioner not to
enter the new quake chamber but this
allow us to do a lot of research on
human spacial hearing in that chamber so
drill in on that a little bit because
coming from a video production
background the air conditioner in a
building is always the annoying part for
the sound people but you've got that
figured out in the way that you've
situated the air-conditioning unit and
so on to remove this rumbling sound from
the air conditioner
we installed a gigantic filter which is
under the floor of the entire equipment
room so think about 6 by 4 meters floor
and this is how we were able to reduce
the sound from the air conditioning
still if you do a very precise
acoustical measurements we have the
ability to switch it off ok so back to
what you had said about having humans in
this room for prolonged periods of time
I've heard that your brain starts to
play tricks on you when you're in that
quiet of a place for a prolonged period
of time what's the deal there ok this is
the human perception of the new quick
chamber humans in general are I would
say two
half dimensional creatures when we walk
on the ground we don't have very good
speech or hearing vertically we do much
better horizontally but also we count on
the first reflection from the ground to
use it as a distance cue when you enter
the new quick chamber you subconsciously
swallow and this is a reaction because
your brain thinks that there is a
difference in the pressure between your
inner ear and the atmosphere which
presses the eardrums and you cannot hear
anything
so that swallowing reaction is what you
do when you're in an airplane and the
pressure actually changes and you get
the same perception in this room but the
pressure didn't change exactly but the
problem in the room is that you cannot
hear anything just because there is no
sound in the chamber and the other thing
what happens is you cannot hear that
reflection from the floor which is
basically very hardwired in our brains
we can distinguish two separate sounds
when the distance between them is a
couple of milliseconds and when the
sound source is far away this difference
between the direct part and the
reflection from the ground is less than
that we hear this as one sound we start
to perceive those two as a separate
sounds when the sound source is closer
than a couple of meters away means two
jumps and then subconsciously alarm
bells start to ring in our brain that
idea is the sound source less than two
jumps away watch out not to became the
dinner or maybe this is the dinner so
the progress though of what your brain
does and what your hearing does inside
the chamber for one minute for 10
minutes what happens so there is no
sound and the brain tries to acquire as
much information as possible in the
situation when you don't get information
is called information
rivo you first after a minute or so
start to hear as to which is actually
the blood in the vessels of your ear
then after couple of minutes you start
to hear your body sounds your heartbeat
your breathing and and there are no
other senses eyes closed it no sound
coming literally you reach after ten
fifty means the stage of audio
hallucinations
our brains are pattern-matching machines
so sooner or later the brain will start
to recognize sounds you have heard
somewhere in different places we people
from my team we have not reached that
stage simply because when you work there
the door is open the tools or clunking
we have conversations etc etcetera but
maybe someday I will have to lay there
and close my eyes and see can reach the
hallucination stage
[Music]
well let's talk about the research
behind Microsoft Kinect and that's been
a huge driver of innovations in this
field tell us how the legacy of research
and hardware for Kinect led to progress
and other areas of Microsoft Kinect
introduces two new modalities in
human-machine interfaces voice and
gesture and it was a wildly successful
product Kinect entered the Guinness Book
of Records for the fastest selling
electronic device in the history of
mankind
Microsoft sold 8 million devices in the
first three months of the beginning of
the production since then most of the
technologies in Kinect have been further
developed but even during the first year
of Kinect Microsoft released Kinect for
Windows which allow it researchers from
all over the globe to do things we even
didn't thought of this is so-called
Kinect effect we had more than 50
startups building their products using
technologies from Microsoft Kinect today
most of them are further developed in
handset and are part of our products
I'll give just two examples the first is
homeless the device does not have a
mouse or keyboard and the human machine
interface is built on three input
modalities gaze gesture and voice in
horns we have a depth camera quite
similar to the one in Kinect and we do
gesture recognition using super refined
and improved algorithms but they
originate from the ones we had in
connect the second example is also
colorless coolants has four microphones
the same number
connect and I would say that the audio
enhancement pipelined forgetting the
voice of the person wearing the device
is the granddaughter of the audio
pipeline we release it in connecting
2010 now let's talk about one of the
coolest projects you're working on it's
the spatial audio or 3d audio what's
your team doing to make the 3d audio
experience a reality in general spatial
audio or 3d audio is a technology that
allows us to project audio sources in
any desired position to be perceived by
the human being wearing headphones this
technology is not something new actually
we have instances of it in mid 19th
century when two microphones in two
rented telephone lines were used for
stereo broadcasting of a theatrical play
later in the 20th century they have been
vinyl records market to be listening
with headphones because they were stereo
recorded using a demi hat with two
microphones in the years this technology
did not fly because of two major
deficiencies the first is you move your
head left and right and the entire Road
you seen rotates with you the second is
that your brain may not exactly like the
special cues coming from the microphones
in the year of the deme head and this is
where you reach the topic of head
related transfer functions literally if
you have a sound source somewhere in the
space the sound from it reaches your
left and right here in a slightly
different way it can be modulated as two
filters and if you filter it through
those two filters and play through
headphones your brain will be received
the sound coming from the undulation if
we know those pairs of filters for all
directions around you this is called
head related transfer fine
the problem is that they are highly
individual head related transfer
functions are formed by the size and the
dimensions of the head the position of
the years the fine structure of the
pinna the reflections from the shoulders
and we did a lot of research to find the
way to quickly generate personalized it
head related transfer functions we put
in our an equal chamber more than 400
subjects we measured their HR TFS we did
the sub millimeter precision scan of
their head and torso and we did
measurement of certain anthropometric
dimensions of those subjects today we
can just measure several dimensions of
your head and generate your personalised
head related transfer function we can do
this even from a depth picture literally
you can tell how you hear from the way
you look and we have polished this
technology to extend that in hololens
you have your spatial what you
personalize it without even knowing it
you put the device on and you hear
through your own personalized it special
hearing how does that do that
automatically silently we measure
certain anthropometrics of your head our
engineering teams our partners decided
that they should not be anything visible
for generation of those personalized
special hearing so if I put this on say
the hololens headset it's going to
measure me on the fly and then the 3d
audio will happen for me both of us
could have the headset on and hear a
noise in one of our ears that's
supposedly coming from behind us but
really isn't correct with the two
loudspeakers in hololens or newer
headphones
we can make perceive the sound coming
from above from below from behind and
this is actually the main difference
between surround sound and TD audio for
headphones surround sound has 5 or 7
loudspeakers but they are all in one
plane
so surround audio world is actually flat
while with this special audio engine we
can actually render audio above can be
low which opens pretty much a new
frontier in expressiveness of the audio
what we can do listen as you talk I have
a vision of a bat in my head
sending out signals and getting signals
and echo locations and would you death
what so one of our projects this is one
of those more blue sky research projects
is exactly about that what we wanted to
explore is using audio as echolocation
in the same way the bass see in complete
darkness and we built a spherical cloud
speaker array of eight strands users
which sent ultra sound pulses towards
given direction and near it eight
element microphone array which through
the technology called beamforming listen
stores the same direction with this we
would you lies the energy of the
loudspeakers well and reduce the amount
of sounds coming from other directions
and this allows us to measure the energy
reflected by the object in that
direction when you do the scanning of
the space you can create an image which
is exactly the same as created from a
depth camera using infrared light but
with a fraction of the energy the
ultimate goal eventually will be to get
the same gesture recognition with one
tenth or one hundredth of the power
necessary this is important for
all portable battery-operated devices
yeah speed of that accessibility is a
huge area of interest for Microsoft
right now especially here in Microsoft
Research with the AI for accessibility
initiative and it's really
revolutionising access to technology for
people with disabilities tell us how the
researcher doing is finding its way into
the projects and products in the arena
of accessibility
you know accessibility finds a resonance
among Microsoft employees the first
application of our spatial audio
technology was actually not hollowness
it was a project which was a kind of a
grassroots project when Microsoft
employees work it with charity
organization called Guide Dogs in United
Kingdom and from the name you can
basically guess that they trained
guiding dogs for people with blindness
the idea was to use the special audio to
help the visually imparied
multiple teams in Microsoft Research
actually have been involved to overcome
a lot of problems including my team and
this whole story ended up with releasing
a product called soundscape which is a
phone application which allows people
with blindness to navigate easier where
the special audio acts like a finger
pointer when the system says and on the
left is the department store actually
that voice prompt came from the
direction where the department store is
and this is additional spatial cue which
helps the orientation of the visually
impaired people another interesting
project we have been involved also is a
grassroots project it was driven by a
girl which was hearing-impaired she
initiated the project during the one of
the yearly hackathons and the project
was triggered by the fact that she was
told by her neighbor that your co2 alarm
is beeping called your week you have to
replace the battery so we created a
phone application which was able to
recognize the number of sounds like co2
alarm fire alarm door knock
phone rings baby crying etc etc and to
signal the hearing-impaired person using
vibration or the display and this is to
help to navigate and to live better life
in our environment
[Music]
you have an interesting personal story
tell us a bit about your background
where did you grow up what got you
interested in the work you're doing and
how did you end up at Microsoft Research
I'm born in a small country in Southeast
Europe called Bulgaria took my diploma
in electronic engineering and PhD in
computer science from the Technical
University of Sofia and immediately
after my graduation started to work as a
researcher there in 1998 I was assistant
professor in this department of
electronic engineering when Microsoft
hired me and I moved to Washington State
spent two full shipping cycles in
Microsoft engineering teams before in
2001 to move in Microsoft Research and
what I have learned during those two
shipping cycles actually helped me a lot
to talk better with the engineers during
the technology transfers I have done
with Microsoft engineering teams yeah
and there's quite a bit of tech transfer
that's coming out of your group what are
some example of the things that have
been blue sky research at the beginning
that are now finding their way into
millions of users desks and homes I have
been lucky enough to be part of very
strong research groups and to learn from
masters like a nob Gupta or Rica Malo
my first project in Microsoft research
was called distributed meetings and we
used the device to record meetings to
store them and to process them later
this device became round table device
which is part of many conference rooms
worldwide then I decided to generalize
the microphone area support I design and
for round table device and this became
the microphone area support in Windows
Vista next challenge was to make this
speech enhancement pipeline to work even
you know
more harsh conditions like the noisy car
and I designed the algorithms and
transfer them to the first speech driven
infotainment system in a mass production
car and then the story continues with
Kinect with hololens many other products
and this is another difference between
industrial research and academia the
satisfaction from your work is
measurable you know - how many homes
your technology has been released to how
many people you change the way they live
entertain your work as we close Yvonne
perhaps you could give some parting
advice to those of our listeners that
might be interested in the science of
sound so to speak what are the exciting
challenges out there in audio and
acoustics research and what guidance
would you offer would be researchers in
this area so audio processing is a very
interesting area of research because it
is a mixture between art craft in
science it is science because we work
with mathematical models and we have
repetitive results but it is an art
because it's about human perception
humans have their own preferences and
tastes and this makes it very difficult
to model it mathematical models and it's
also a craft there are always some more
tricks in secret Souls which are not
mathematical models but make the
algorithms from one lab work much better
than the algorithms from another lab
into the mixture we have to add the
powerful invasion of machine learning
technologies neural networks and
artificial intelligence which allow us
to solve problems we thought were
unsolvable and to produce algorithms
which were much better than the classic
ones so the advices over a signal
processing and machine link
this combination is very powerful even
Tosh's thank you for joining us today
thank you to learn more about dr. Yvonne
Tasha and how Microsoft Research is
working to make sound sound better visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]